People go to movies to be distracted and entertained.
That's basically the reason movies exist.
Sometimes, those movies are so good at doing
their job that they manage to distract audiences
even with glaring plot holes or lapses in
logic.
Not many people kicked up a fuss over some
of the dumbest moments in these 2017 movies,
so we're here to shed light on them.
Get ready to tear a few holes in some of 2017's
best flicks.
Spoilers ahead.
A simple message
Spider-Man: Homecoming's ferry scene was a
lot of fun, but it never would have happened
if not for a plot hole bigger than the hole
Vulture put in that ferry.
The only reason that whole sequence happened
is because Tony Stark didn't think it was
important enough to send a quick reply to
his protégé.
To elaborate, let's go back to the awkward
argument between Iron Man and Spidey.
"Those weapons were out there and I tried
to tell you about it but you didn't listen.
None of this would have happened if you had
just listened to me."
"I did listen, kid.
Who do you think called the FBI, hun?"
It's great that Stark was paying attention,
but that would have been a nice thing to mention
before Peter tried to stop everyone himself.
Honestly, young Peter Parker wasn't acting
insubordinate when he boarded that ferry.
He was simply doing his heroic duty because
he thought no one else was going to.
All of the movie's troubles following the
ferry scene — like him fighting Vulture
solo in a sweatshirt instead of his high tech
suit — are a direct result of Tony's inability
to respond to messages in a timely manner.
A simple text to say the FBI was handling
it would've saved everyone a lot of headaches.
Unfortunately, the world's most notoriously
irresponsible billionaire playboy just couldn't
be bothered to do something that simple.
Assassin incentives
Toward the final third of John Wick: Chapter
2, John breaks some rules and scores a seven-million-dollar
bounty on his head.
Thanks to this bounty, all of the assassins
in New York City pop out of the woodwork and
try to take a stab at Wick.
What doesn't make sense here is that in the
previous movie, there was a two-million-dollar
bounty on Wick's head and not one random assassin
perked up at the offer.
When the offer got doubled to four-million,
only one ultra-desperate assassin tried to
take on Wick, and it didn't end well.
This lack of challenge stems from the fact
that Wick has a reputation for being the underworld
boogeyman.
"John wasn't exactly the boogeyman.
He was the one you sent to kill the f------
boogeyman."
Yet in John Wick 2, everyone and their grandmother
gave it a shot for seven million, boogeyman
or not.
"Seven million dollars is a lot of money,
Mr. Wick."
But is it enough to warrant going after the
man who single-handedly dismantled the Russian
mob?
It just doesn't add up.
Not-so-secret island
As great as Wonder Woman was, it was chock-full
of dumb moments.
How was Steve Trevor able to infiltrate the
German army without a shred of identification
or the ability to speak German with a proper
accent?
How was Wonder Woman able to cross no-man's
land without any of these bullets hitting
her?
Moments like these were overlooked in favor
of the movie's many strong points, but it
doesn't change the fact that the plot was
sloppy.
The clearest example of this is when Themyscira
is discovered by Steve Trevor, the first man
to stumble upon it — even though it's clearly
within arm's reach of England and uses an
invisibility shield that's penetrable by literally
anyone.
Think about it: Diana and Steve use a sailboat
to reach London from Themyscira in one night,
so the Amazons' secret island has to be pretty
close - even with a tug to tow them partway.
Morning.
We got lucky, we caught a ride, made some
good time."
And considering Steve could randomly fly through
the island's cloaking shield, as could the
Nazi boats following him, it's ludicrous to
suggest that no one had stumbled upon Themyscira
before that.
Ape ex machina
For such a great movie, War for the Planet
of the Apes sure stumbles when detailing how
the apes manage to outmaneuver their captors
at the film's climax: From within the confines
of a maximum security penitentiary that has
guards patrolling 24/7, dozens of apes are
able to sneak away via a convenient hole in
the dirt floor of their cell.
Not one guard notices all the apes vanishing
from the cell.
And, as if that weren't preposterous enough,
the movie then sends all the young chimps
across electrical wires, right above guards'
heads.
Not one guard happens to look up?
None of those roving spotlights casts a monkey-shaped
shadow on the ground?
Even though all of this happens at night,
an entire internment camp's worth of chimps
aren't just going to slink away within a few
hours completely unnoticed.
Forgotten blob
Toward the end of Guardians of the Galaxy
Vol. 2, Ego unleashes an alien tumor that
starts gobbling up Earth.
This blob grows to massive proportions, wreaking
havoc on an entire town before it's stopped.
Given that the prologue took place in 1980,
and the rest of the movie was set 34 years
later, it's pretty safe to assume all that
blobbing happened around 2014 in the MCU's
chronology.
So you'd think there would be some mention
of it across the bevy of other MCU movies
that take place after that.
But everyone just seems to have forgotten
about that little town in Missouri...and all
the places that got wrecked by Ego's blue
goo.
Suspicious resurrection
At the very end of Justice League, we see
that Superman has revived his Clark Kent alter-ego.
But...isn't that kind of suspicious?
A little, maybe?
A lot of people saw him get buried.
While returning from the grave might not be
a big deal for Kal-El, humans don't really
tend to do that.
At least, not without something getting thrown
at them.
"Now what?
"We'll have to get more stuff."
Even worse, Kent worked for the Daily Planet.
None of those investigative journalist co-workers
thought it was fishy that his demise and return
perfectly coincided with Superman's?
These policemen couldn't put it together after
Lois said his name in front of everyone?
"Clark."
The only explanation is that Clark Kent was
revived solely so that he could tear his shirt
open at the end of the film.
That's a good reason, right?
Missing Sif
For all the fun Thor: Ragnarok provides, some
things just don't make sense — specifically,
the absence of the warrior Lady Sif.
Basically, Sif doesn't seem to exist anymore.
After having a serious role in the first Thor
movie and an appearance in Thor: The Dark
World, Lady Sif is nowhere to be found during
the destruction of Asgard.
Even the Warriors Three got an ending to their
arcs, as anticlimactic as it was.
The fact that Sif got snubbed just seems like
a massive oversight.
Marvel head Kevin Feige did give a vague explanation
for her absence, saying:
"What has Loki been doing on that throne in
guise of Odin?
He would have to get rid of Heimdall, because
Heimdall can see everything.
[...] which is probably an answer to a question
I've been asked a few times today: Sif was
probably banished.
She's off somewhere."
Well, that could work — but Heimdall was
banished and still got a story arc.
Sif didn't even get a tacked-on death scene
or a line of dialogue that addresses her absence.
She's just … not there.
Silly humans
Kong: Skull Island is a big, silly movie about
a big gorilla.
It's a lot of fun, but let's face it: You
don't go into this kind of thing expecting
a watertight plot.
Still, one plot decision made absolutely no
sense.
Here's the scoop: A team of researchers and
soldiers are tasked with infiltrating Skull
Island, which is surrounded by a permanent
storm.
"Like the Bermuda Triangle or like that aluminum
foil hat I like to wear on the weekends."
To pass through this natural hazard, they
bring a massive ship … and then abandon
it in favor of a few open-doored helicopters.
Sure, they needed the ship intact to get them
away from the island again, but they could
have gotten a lot closer on the boat rather
than brave hurricane winds in a few helicopters.
"How far away is this island?
"50 miles.
Maybe more?
Take us closer."
"You want to launch, do it from here."
Gee, thanks, random boat guy.
Minimum maximum security
At the outset of Ghost in the Shell, super-soldier
cyborg Major is created to do the bidding
of a sinister corporation.
When she stops following orders, the company's
goons trap Major in a maximum security fortress.
Well, as it turns out, the facility isn't
very secure at all.
All it takes for Major to bust out of there
is a light scuffle with a few guards and then
some off-screen action.
Had the movie played by its own rules, she
would've been stopped before she escaped from
her deactivation bed.
This whole set piece, and the sequence within
it, is just poorly thought out.
"Maybe next time you can design me better."
Thanks for watching!
Click the Looper icon to subscribe to our
YouTube channel.
Plus check out all this cool stuff we know
you'll love, too!